are you money yeah what brings you here
I don't know Phyllis made me come my
sister huh she must be very persuasive
don't tell me about yourself
I run a Fabrics company so you're the
boss I feel good it feels
Phyllis has always been the strong one
you're a grown man hiding behind a wall
of curtains I think I can help you the
first thing I'm going to do is
completely unethical I'm going to give
you a hug I'm a hugger
there's no shame in feeling pain Marty
need a ruler of your own domain
work begins at 9am shopping I
Phyllis I'm trying to be ruler of my own
domain this therapy is really working
out huh it is it really is
the goal of life is to live we'll turn
you into the man you truly deserve to be
the doctor's a little unconventional
he's a miracle worker what is he doing
here
helping us what do you think so much fun
is that allowed well it didn't work
didn't I you change my life
my
life
me you clearly have a good eye me the
other one with the good eye eyes two
eyes the the appropriate quota of ocular
spheres why are we running I don't know
Rob you're a growing Marty
psychiatrist business partner best
friend how does all of that work he just
has no boundaries and I don't trust him
cut her out of your life she's the only
family I have
without trust we have nothing I trust
you completely
this is my decision he's living in your
head I am going to take care of
everything
feels good doesn't it
[Music]